The joe rogan experience.
Why wouldn't we assume that the reason why we're so conflicted and weird is
because that's the proper mechanism that needs to be in place for people to move
forward in the direction that we're moving forward.
It'd be,
it'd be constantly chasing technology without any real clear sort of a rational
approach to using our resources and looking at the problems that we have because
we're like a bunch of little kids that have like shit all over their house,
but instead we're,
we're outside working on the garden,
you know,
we're planting trees,
we're not cleaning up the shit that we piled up in the middle of the living room
and it keeps piling up every day to the point where we can't even live in our
house anymore and we're concentrating on some shit that's not even ours.
Do you think you could ever,
you probably couldn't,
but maybe in your,
maybe it stayed,
like if you didn't have kids,
in fact big family.
So do you think you could ever live in like one of those airstream trailers by
myself?
Fuck yeah.
Cause I was recently,
I recently went to Joshua tree and one of those and I was thinking like,
really this is all I really need and I could take my whole fucking house
anywhere I want.
And the new ones have like nice wood floors
and some of them expand out.
You know,
there's,
there's been,
um,
you know,
a lot of people that are moving towards minimalist houses,
really small houses,
but there's a bunch of online that show like how certain people live.
And it's kind of interesting,
you know,
like one guy figured out a way to have like this little tiny cooking area and he
pulls the bed out in the bed,
comes out of the wall.
He lives by himself and he has like some storage up in top,
like toilet paper and things along those lines.
But it's a tiny,
tiny little house and a little kitchen dinette area.
And you know,
the idea is that like,
really,
why do we have to have this giant fucking footprint of House that we live in?
You know,
and
these guys are getting paid,
bitch,
if all I live in a fucking cell,
I'll live in a fucking sound like a monkey.
I'm going to live on a fault
Puerto Rican that gets a check on the fifth.
Go Fuck your mother.
If you get paid,
you live in a fucking house.
I'm going to live in a Mike Rowe fucking house with a little kitchen.
The Cook,
like I got a black guy back at me in the fucking ass.
I don't need that.
You spread out even me.
I'm no millionaire.
I've got a big fucking kitchen,
a micro house.
What do you fucking people talking about?
I just not thought of it though.
You can't take me into those deep waters like Rico.
Fucking kill the brother right now.
A fucking house with a bed upside down.
Fuck that shit to say vantage of fuck you.
You get paid.
You fucking live like a normal person going to Trump and say,
hey wig.
Move into a fucking thing to say but it to see if you don't pick slap you.
If you don't have a Russian bitch slapping in the fucking fire,
the fuck are these people,
micro houses in the fucking desert.
You play it out to the world that like a doctor like a doctor.
You live your fucking life.
You're right.
Dooms Day.
I'm going to put a can of tomato soup under my stairs to wait for the Marshall
to come.
When it's over,
it's over.
You got when they with your Dick out and you take your fucking chances like a
man.
I'm gonna live like I fucking old.
$20 to a bookmaker downstairs in my house.
Get the fuck out of my face.
I want to live in one of the airstream.
Brian's down.
Joey's not.
I think we have a real clear line.
We feel like you're in one.
When you're in there,
it's,
it's pretty.
So somebody farts and you're in four fucking speak for Lisa and you're like,
I paid $10,000 it's like a smell your asshole.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Because everything's great.
In a small space.
They'll suddenly blows a fucking for you will walk into a bathroom at the,
some of the Oh shit bothers you.
Even if they're your mother.
You look at them like you dirty fucking Vicks,
light a candle,
slumped it live.
Nothing small.
Fuck that shit,
Bro.
Especially,
I'm never home though.
You know,
like I work so much.
I'm never hiding.
You're always fucking hall.
I'm home asleep.
Yeah.